[Musik]
guten Morgen aus San Diego wir gehen
heute an den Strand
[Musik]
Leute ich habe einfach das
allerwichtigste vergessen
wenn wir schon einer surfstart sind
müssen wir auch wenigstens versuchen zu
surfen jetzt kommen wir wirklich einen
Strang jetzt aber ne hier sind wir jetzt
also am wunderbaren Strand Ocean Beach
und wir gucken direkt mal was ist hier
leckeres zu Essen bestellen gibt weil
das ist ja wie gesagt das heutige Video
wir gucken nach dem besten Restaurant
welches hier in San Diego liefert
eigentlich wollten wir das in Los
Angeles machen aber da gab es einfach so
viele dass man nicht nach dem besten
Filtern konnte checke ich auch nicht so
wirklich wir sind hier auf jeden Fall
jetzt am George stefanoff Ocean beach
volleyball court wir machen das ganz
schnell nach Bewertung filtern was
brauchen wir keine Filter los geht's der
obere ist beworben glaube ich oder die
ersten beiden Punkte sind auf jeden Fall
Eis Eiscreme einmal Ben und Jerry's und
einmal Stella Jones ice cream sehe ich
mich aber ich habe auf jeden Fall auch
Lust auf was richtiges da hätten wir
nämlich sentennis Mexican Grill San
Diego ist ja relativ nah an der
mexikanischen Grenze also eine halbe
Stunde Autofahrt und da ist man glaube
ich schon drüber deshalb was erwartbar
das hier mexikanisches Essen sein könnte
ihr wisst ja ich liebe mexikanisches
Essen ich guck sein was die so am Start
haben Burrito kalifornia burritu Kana
sada Burrito Grid chicken Burrito viele
verschiedene Dinge Mini Tacos TJ Style
okay also wir haben viel mexikanisch
gegessen schon in den letzten Tagen ist
da werde ich sagen können wie gut das
ist es gibt auf jeden Fall viele viele
Burritos Tacos und das war's Burrito
echt gut bewerten weil wir auch bei uns
sehr sehr gute haben das werden wir
sehen auf unsere wirklich sehr sehr gut
sind also Bay Area Burrito company in
Köln ist sehr sehr gut schmeckt mir
zumindest sehr sehr lecker ja California
Burrito muss ich eigentlich nehmen Cana
sada Grill chicken als shot the chicken
kanitas und adobada vielleicht sowas wie
Adobe Extras brauche ich keine ich nehme
das wieder kommt beverages found and
drinks und Aquas freskas Drink ich
bestelle das einfach mal bestelle ich
mal oder bestelle ich mir noch ein paar
Tacos dazu ja komm machaca Mini Tacos
reddit beef with onions tomato Screen
Peppers crumbled egg white source Grill
Jack und Cortina sag Bestellung schickt
gerade let's go Bestellung erhalten und
wir gucken direkt mal was es sonst noch
so gibt es gibt aber eine Sache die ich
sehr sehr gerne noch dazu bestellen
würde einfach so es hat was mit unserem
Büro Kollegen zu tun
ja
im Urlaub Leute wir müssen ja alles
nicht so ganz genau nehmen ein tender
und ein Slider mit Preis zweite
Bestellung geht raus wir sehen uns
gleich wenn das Essen da ist die erste
Bestellung ist da hier haben wir die Ort
chaba genauso werden die Leute hier
sagen aber ist wahrscheinlich die
offizielle Aussprache so wie man es
kennt in einem sehr kompakten Getränk
kompakter einer Beta Cup das ist
wahrscheinlich wirklich ein Liter hier
probier's direkt mal weil ich weiß
wirklich nicht wie es schmecken welche
Farbe das hat oder das ist so milchig
Alter ja komisch ne das ist ja echt
jetzt Milch irgendwie wirst und dann
gucke ich nach was drin ist
vielleicht auf jeden Fall nichts für
tizi weil da sehr viel Zimt drin ist
boah es schmeckt so ich finde es sehr
lecker schmeckt so wie eine Mischung aus
eigentlich ja wie ein Charlotte ja wie
ein kalter charlotte ist auf jeden Fall
schon mal ein Apparat dann haben wir
hieroform Behälter mit Tacos ein paar
dipping Saucen hier haben wir es also
ganz was da drauf ist ne
Adobe heißt scheinbar habe ich gerade
nachgeschaut einfach mariniert Guacamole
oben drauf was man sowas zum Strand
bestellen kann ist irgendwie auch schon
ist schon Flex so generell San Diego
gefällt uns super gut bisher ich habe
auch ein Podcast oder von geschwärmt
Halle zwei werde ich wusste dass wir
einen haben aber
probieren wir die Mini Tacos
die sind wirklich sehr sehr gut ja wir
haben viele viel Tacos gegessen aber die
sind so richtig so schön weich und so
weißt du okay wir sehen auch gut beladen
aus vielleicht ist es der Hunger
vielleicht sind sie auch einfach nur
krank
leckeres auch sehr lecker Eric möchtest
du ausprobieren probiere auch einmal
Alter das Ei drin ja wollte gerade sagen
das ist prambled eggs drauf
ich kann kein Eiben und mit Avocado mehr
essen aber das ist mein persönliches
Problem das schmeckt sehr sehr lecker
eine entschuldigt sich
zehn vor zehn Digger fünf von fünf
schauen wir uns an unseren Burrito das
haben wir hier noch gar nicht gegessen
genau
ich erinnere mich jetzt ich dachte die
Pommes keinen extra aber sie sind drin
einfach bombendöner sagt jetzt sie
gerade
aber ich glaube viel geiler als POM
Döner oder das liebe ich ne beim
mexikanischen Essen immer so dieses
scheiß hast das macht Spaß beim Essen so
das ist einfach nicht so stumm du musst
so bisschen noch so adden aber du kannst
genau die Menge tun die Du möchtest
ist da auch Ei drauf ne sehr lecker
gerade mit der Salsa hätte man nicht
erwartet oder bist ja so kommt ja ich
hatte keine Pommes da drin erwartet aber
scheint so ein Ding zu sein also die
Pommes schaffen es irgendwie zumindest
hat man das Gefühl dass man ein bisschen
knusprig sind und leichte Schärfe hat
man drin hier in dieser geschmolzener
Käse an der Innenwand des Burritos und
kann dann durch die Soßen kommt das
ganze erst so richtig zum Leben weil es
dadurch erst so saftig wird also es ist
nicht trocken so sondern man muss halt
einfach viel kauen trotzdem aber sehr
geschmackvoll damit den Soßen ist sehr
sehr krass also jetzt im Vergleich
wirklich mal zu so einem Burrito Rico
oder einem barrier bei uns in Köln
schmeckt ganz anders ist ein ganz
anderer burrit also es ist auf jeden
Fall ganz anders als man es kennen aber
das will man ja auch wenn man hier am
anderen Ende der Welt ist wenn du
entscheiden müsstest ganz anders besser
oder ganz anders schlechter welche
Tendenz würdest du eingehen
wenn ich nur noch eins von beidem essen
dürfte im Burrito den wir in Köln
nehmen echt ja krass ja das muss man das
mehr so mein Bild von einem Burrito ist
weil ich glaube die anderen möchten auch
gerne probieren und wir müssen die
nächste Bestellung probieren ich fand
sehr geil ich bin froh dass ich bestellt
habe gerade auch so dieses Getränk hier
schauen wir mal wie sehr mich das
Chicken aus dem Leben Schalter wird
nächste ab Dave's hot chicken und ich
sage so viel es hat uns komplett
abgeholt das war aber auch der erste Tag
wo wir so unterwegs waren in LA da haben
wir das Vergessen und wir sind richtig
angekommen so weil das ist natürlich
auch dass man sich so von Amerika
erhofft und vorstellt einfach so Fast
Food in so Dimensionen wie wir es gar
nicht kennen was will man mehr oder also
wir haben ganz typisch hier so dicke
Pickels und Riffeln geschnitten auch
riftige Pommes wir haben einen chicken
tender mit so einer knusprigen Panade
das fühlt man sogar und dann ein
schicken Sandwich welches so dieses
klassische Bahn hat was so ein bisschen
wie Knete ist wie schön ist es denn das
hier ist die DAVE source die hatten wir
auch schon das ist glaube ich einfach so
Ketchup Mayo gemischt damit muss jetzt
mal eine Pommes testen aber eigentlich
ist das so eine schlechte Verpackung im
Pommes zu liefern weil der so voll
labbelig werden in diesem Styropor
kriegen wir das hier besser hin
nein
generell Pommes in Amerika haben uns ja
seltenst überzeugt ja was jetzt chicken
tender oder chicken Sandwich okay komm
gehen wir rein oh das ist so mit Liebe
gemacht von innen getoastet Coleslaw
ordentlich so Pickels drauf um die
Hotspots wahrscheinlich wow
[Musik]
werden es öfters essen sollen glaube ich
ich werde es vermissen boah ich werde es
wirklich vermissen das ist so lecker ja
nur mal das schicken mit der Source das
ist so komplett überladen so mit so
Gewürzen und so würde ich auch in
Deutschland niemals machen einfach so so
Gewürzgurken erst einmal in Amerika sag
mal Gehirn das ist normal mach keinen
großen Unterschied probier noch mal den
Tender ja auch eine stattliche Größe hat
eigentlich wollten wir nur das beste
Restaurant testen aber das musst du noch
sehen ist neben shake-check auf jeden
Fall die beste Fast Food Kette die wir
getestet haben also ich glaube man
kriegt nirgendwo KFC träumt davon so so
saftiges chicken zu machen ich hoffe ihr
habt den weit gefühlt es war heute ein
bisschen mehr so ein Ding so Urlaubstag
mit euch teilen natürlich trotzdem was
geiles Essen die anderen gucken schon
wieder hungrig aufs Essen deshalb würde
ich sagen danke fürs zusehen bis zum
nächsten Video und wir sehen uns ciao